[Music]
Ryan Reynolds was named one of gqueues
men of the year at Thursday's party in
LA but he couldn't stop gushing over his
highest honor being a proud dad and
husband I would guess your ladies at
home are happy for you about this honor
how does it feel does get you some cool
points at home humanity yeah cool points
I got a few more cool points at home for
like you know changing a diaper or
something like that but yeah this is
this discussant stock ever yeah it's
pretty great yeah well how does it feel
now that the family has expanded is your
new little one anything like her older
sister how is she doing being a big
sister well they look alike you know you
can see that she's a sort of mini
version of our older girl but no it's
it's great I mean it's like a actual
cohesive working functioning family it's
amazing to see my older daughter take
care of the younger one and sort of yeah
you know it's the Lion King was right
the circle of life exists I admire your
lovely wife because she's posting on
Instagram but how she's working out and
eating right to get back in shape how do
you support her in that and how proud
are you of her I don't know of what your
speak with us getting back in shape
spent astok so um yeah I I don't know I
mean it's a yeah whatever we do to we do
to stay healthy is what we do that's
great
you
[Music]